and logo and welcome to this video
playing the cross shock so I got some
I'm ready gambit and let's see if it
takes it does okay here always confusing
remove orders okay yeah it's an
interesting idea that i recently found I
mean not like invented but found in the
database queen d 4 is not good for black
and I'd see for Queen a one Bishop e2
three Nate to Quincy to and the Queen
will be trapped on a two black should
just take on be 3m and then we have an
interesting position where i have
written in compensation for the porn but
black is definitely i'm also having
decent chances
yeah going to develop as quickly as
possible put pressure on the pawn on c6
I probably should have played a five
first and this is something that i
missed here it's because a shame to be
honest
okay so what's going on here I can try
something brutal I like f 4 and so on
but it's probably not the greatest idea
ever I it's just a shame that I allowed
him to play five definitely playing too
quickly them
so 97 96 hmm still should work right
scanning a little bit more space here
uh-huh this was the idea ok I have to
take anyway
knight c6 could be a strong move here
checking d 45 ignores the night but he
attacks my bishop hmmm he found it he
has found it shoot let's not good at all
you have to get something going here
shuffling around won't i won't cut it
just back after that weakness was
provoked
when it gets messy now ok so i have c 6
now it's 95 their own it4s Queen to c6
Wow
Quincy 6 queen of three years this isn't
all that grade for him 9 f 6m
threatening also look 26 cm getting
everything going now I think this is
good for white
so now 95 maybe that's a very cheeky
looking more I can still take that maybe
you have to play something
check rookie 584 screenie to time
warning
97 rookie cell mate and everything hangs
I don't give me that ok I can I please
do this check check
how are they still self protect each
other no check check check check check
mate oh my god yo select me who I will
stir it up okay I should have a key role
in somewhere would can I was very very
complicated so let's have a look down
listen is an interesting move so he took
it here here and now I should play this
more i think i forgot about it so just
forget about it um this is a lot better
to prevent like from going a five and
like solidify this structure yeah i have
chances to play against the before porn
as well and this is a lot better than
this i mean here this is also a
compensation somehow but the other
position i like much better yes c5 now
that's it's guess get best ball that
gets crazy now this and 96 so strong
with a fat chick here black it's
extremely fine so i had to do this and
age 5 m and this is not great
yeah it's a whole mesum it's a whole
mess and engine wants to take here
interestingly enough i cannot take the
night at this one okay then this is so
strong it's still very murky but it
should be better for black with the big
pawns keep this happened 93 Emmy missed
some chances now I'm fine yeah now
winning with yeah this probably wasn't
the best then check however the engine
still gives me win so it wasn't all that
terrible this and now I need some clear
open I am this this I could I should
just take here because he cannot take
because of Knight f6 that makes this a
far clearer win the way it went check
check it wasn't all that easy especially
with this time now with chicks I could
have picked up the rope but my problem
was I was actually thinking I would win
win one of them which I don't and now
it's probably a draw at the Kennedy
scramble chest haha check managed to
made him okay I was a tough game thanks
for watching